we're gonna begin with this president
pump is returning to the southern border
today to wrap up a startling week in
us-mexican relations it began with a
threat to shut down the border to keep
out drugs and waves of asylum seekers
from Central America yesterday the
president said he will give Mexico one
year to step up its drug and immigration
enforcement that reprieve came with the
threat of penalties on cars and other
products imported from Mexico we would
start with the tariffs and we'll see
what happens but they are removing
people out of Mexico on the way up to
the United States chip Reid is along the
border in Calexico California where the
president will visit later today chip
good morning well good morning the
president will take a tour of the wall
which you can see right here and the
border crossing which is down that way a
few hundred yards the president says
that ever since he issued his threat to
close the border completely Mexico has
done a better job slowing down the flow
of people across the border so for now
at least he's changed his mind about
closing it we're gonna give him a
one-year warning president Trump isn't
shutting down the border at least for
now and if the drugs don't stop were
largely stopped we're going to put
tariffs on Mexico and products in
particular cars and if that doesn't stop
the drugs we closed the border that's a
far cry from president Trump's urgent
language last Friday if they don't stop
them
with closing the border they'll close it
and we'll we'll keep it closed for a
long time I'm not playing games he had
been ramping up calls from Mexico to
crack down on illegal crossings if they
don't and I'm telling you right now
we will close the damn border
about 1.7 billion dollars of goods and
services flow across the border daily
according to the US Chamber of Commerce
and the potential economic impact
worried even his allies closing down the
border would have potentially
catastrophic economic impact on our
country there would be a lot of
unintended consequences closing legal
crossings that the border would be
devastated
the president changed his tune on
Thursday and I would say this that
Mexico in the last four days has really
done a great job I don't think we'll
ever have to close the border though he
tried to walk back his 1-year deadline
within the span of the day no I didn't
say that
look at us we would start with the
tariffs and we'll see what happens for
now Republicans are breathing a little
easy bruising all wet from ins do dumb
things and it really would have been a
mistake
now what the president will see today is
exactly the kind of state-of-the-art
border wall that he wants razor wire at
the bottom razor wire at the top 30 feet
tall slats
so you can see through it but it's going
to be billions of dollars and a very
long time before the entire border looks
like this
Anthony some stare look and stuff chip
Reid thanks chip